[Musique]
paul roll rioche le patron de la cinq
minutes oui toi
à
certes
manille est bon on va péter une fois en
soir tu prends moi la tendresse à
reprendre sa partie seulement par terre
et delga du tigre correspondent à une
vérité historique
en 1907 la france connait c'est une
réconnaissance insensé de la criminalité
il y avait en france à l'époque plus de
130 crimes importants et georges
clemenceau qui est émise l'intérieur
l'époque décida d'organiser un corps de
police un corps de police différent car
il devait travailler avec méthode
complètement différente moderne et
l'employé voitures automobiles qu'ils
allaient tenter un truc est relativement
rare employer des méthodes telles que
les empreintes digitales et machines
avec usa et en france fut créé un corps
de police qui s'appelait à l'époque des
brigades mobiles et qui fut appelé plus
tard les brigades du tigre à coups de
deals clemenceau est en quelque sorte
qu'ils étaient les incorruptibles
français de l'époque
mais si okada de passage en europe a
bien voulu nous faire l'honneur de
procéder à une démonstration d'une
technique de lutte en usage dans son
pays comment appelez-vous ses filles
déjà figées et
j'ai pensé que tu pourrais lui donner la
réplique - ah monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]